hey 42 here videogames are now the
biggest entertainment industry in the
world 47 billion dollars worth of video
games were sold worldwide in 2014 that's
more than both the music and film
industries and teenagers are now more
addicted to video games than ever before
a staggering 94 percent of teenage girls
and 99% of teenage boys play video games
on a regular basis with so many modern
games requiring fast reaction times and
lightning quick reflexes dose playing
video games actually have any real and
lasting effects on our reaction times in
day-to-day life let's find out most
contemporary video games such as call of
duty Halo Grand Theft Auto and hundreds
more require extremely fast processing
of sensory information to play in this
respect they push the limits of how fast
a human brain can process information
and make decisions based on that
information
video games force our brains to think
and respond faster than is needed in
typical everyday life this is compounded
by the fact that most video games offer
incentives for players to react even
faster to situations in most games
faster reactions lead to awards such as
increased kills and faster lap times to
name what a few examples now they say
practice makes perfect and it's
undeniably true when we do anything in
life electrical impulses are sent
between the neurons in our brain and the
more we do that thing the stronger the
link becomes between those neurons and
the faster they can communicate which
subsequently speeds up the rate at which
we perform the task this is exactly how
practice improves performance practice
actually alters the physical structure
of our brain cells to quicken the flow
of information so if that logic is true
with everything else we do in life
shouldn't it be the same for video games
should it not be the case that the more
we play fast paced video games the
faster are we
and time should be in every day tasks
well yes just like with everything else
we do playing video games does indeed
strengthen the links between the neurons
and our brains that's are related to
processing and reacting to information
this was proved to be true by a recent
study by the department of brain and
cognitive science at the University of
Rochester the researchers took dozens of
18 to 25 year olds who were not
ordinarily video game players God knows
how they found these peculiar teenagers
that don't play video games they then
split the subjects into two groups one
group played 50 hours of two
particularly fast paced games Unreal
Tournament and Call of Duty 2 the other
group played 50 hours of the
significantly slower simulation game The
Sims 2 afterwards both teams were asked
to complete several tasks that were
designed to test a reaction and
cognitive thinking skills for example
the participants were asked to look at a
screen that showed a bunch of
erratically moving dots moving left and
right across the screen the participants
were then tested on how quickly they
could answer a simple question are the
dots moving left or right they also
underwent auditory reaction tests to
analyze how quickly both teams reacted
to sound as well as visual information
and the result well the team that played
the fast-moving action game through a
whole 25 percent faster at answering the
questions and completing the tests than
the other team who had spent the morning
building virtual houses with pretty
white picket fences but the action games
didn't just improve their reaction times
the researchers found that they also
answered the questions more accurately
than the other team the research team
concluded that players at fast paced
video games would prove to be much
better at critical real-life situations
that require fast reactions and quick
thinking such as performing surgery or
being on a battlefield and I do mean a
real battlefield not one made of pixels
reacting to a situation is all about how
fast we can come to a decision about the
challenge we have been
is entered with our brain doses by
rapidly gathering information from our
surroundings both visual and auditory it
then puts this information together and
computes the best possible way to react
for example when driving if a car pulls
out in front of you from a junction
without warning your brain rapidly makes
a decision based on how fast you are
traveling in relation to the other car
as well as other factors to determine
whether or not you should slam on the
brakes all this information is passed
between neurons in our brain in just a
few milliseconds however people who
regularly play video games and therefore
have strengthened the connections
between those neurons those connections
are called axons by the way would be
able to process this information
significantly faster and make the same
decision in a fraction of the time as a
non video game player potentially saving
lives in some situations so when your
parents ask you why you spend so much
time playing video games simply tell
them you're practicing for a
life-or-death situation thanks for the
view subscribe for more 42